hey it's evan and i like to share the
tools that i'm using to grow my business
to save my time and one that i really
enjoy using
is
a tool on a pc called snipping tool now
i love being able to take partial
screenshots and this is basically where
you can take a piece of a screen and not
all of it so we all have the print
screen button on our computer
a really cool feature about the mac
that's built in with shortcuts is if i
only wanted to take a screenshot of say
you know this this part here these hot
google searches if i wanted to take a
screenshot of that i couldn't do it
automatically on my computer or my pc
i'd have to
do a full screen shot take it to
photoshop or take it to paint and then
crop it then save it it's just a lot of
hassle headache mac has this built in
and then once i got used to that feature
i come back to my pc i'm like i need
this on my computer how do i get it
going so i looked up a tool that i've
been using ever since it's called the
snippet tool so let me load it here so
what happens when you load it this is
what happens okay it's this really cool
tiny little program when it shows up it
makes your entire screen
kind of whitewashed and it gives you
this little plus sign here so what i can
do is i can highlight any area of the
screen that i want to promote or take a
copy of so in this case i'll just do
this click and drag you see that it kind
of lightens up before and after
and then that's it so i've got this
screenshot just the picture that i
wanted i can
save it i can copy it i can email it
whatever i want it just saves me a whole
bunch of time instead of doing regular
screenshots maybe a little trick but one
that i love using i got used for my mac
and i had to find a way for the pc this
is the best way i found snipping tool go
check it out
uh what's the website
let me just find it
yeah there you go so it's actually built
by microsoft so that's cool so just go
to snipping tool into google
and you'll find it enjoy let me know
what you guys think you like this video
give it a thumbs up
let me know leave a comment underneath
you have a question for me i'll make a
video response and click on my face at
the top right of the screen to subscribe
to the channel see more videos thank you
guys i'll see you soon